il mio fidanzato di notte ha deciso di
acquistare 5 litri di acqua di mare
suona messaggio ciao ragazzi bentornati
in una puntata di vita buttata il tema
della puntata di oggi è acquisti inutili
per fare una chiacchiera su un tema così
importante ho deciso di invitare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona con la quale in passato ho
parlato di acquisti ho parlato di regali
ma non ho mai avuto l'onore di parlare
di regali inutili che noi ci siamo fatti
a noi stessi ecco perché ho l'onore di
presentarvi il rullo di tamburi matteo
bruno matteo è un onore averti qui anche
per me questo video in collaborazione
con actionaid che si occupa di adozioni
a distanza è bello aprire che format
così pregni di significato possano dare
una mano e anche tornare utili alla
causa un pochino più importante qualcuno
di voi potrebbe chiedersi perché questo
è ma legato a questa iniziativa che la
maggior parte delle persone che devono
dare una mano qualcuno ti dicono eh ma
io sono 100 100 mila spese valestra
questo questo questo caso poi vai a
vedere le loro case in un anno ti sei
comprato almeno 40 cagate quest'ora
avrei salvato come minimo il volto amico
che dire a questo punto visto che
parleremo meglio di tutta questa cosa
alla fine partire subito ciao io po di
anni fa non so per chi ha comprato in
aree che sarebbe servito a raddrizzare
il naso che ha assunto anche un colore
molto strano
io che senso che c'è questi vanno nel
naso io pure ho pensato stessa cosa però
io penso sia stato un ottimo acquisto
complimenti io ho comprato ora che ci
perso due tutori per gli alluci valli
vuoi vedere che si usano piacerebbe ora
non ricordo bene e ti faccio vedere
perché quelle di ma la luce e all'uso di
arezzo tax ossia ecco vedete come unito
rimane tipo staccato e vorrei capire il
giorno in cui tu stavi al computer hai
fatto adesso cercherò me l'hanno
consigliato chi grazie sempre piacere
voi per il vostro ufficio ad assen docs
non avete mai preso quelle cavolate tipo
cose per quando fai la golf io ho avuto
per un periodo il golf da cesso buco
cosa vi per sbattere la pallina ci sono
quelle cose che tu l'istante in cui lo
compri zai già non serve più finché non
paghi è l'oggetto più incredibile del
giorno ciao voce ospita era lontano 2011
viveva poco da sola del tornato a casa
ubriaco marcio
avevo una jacquard inverno non avevo
l'appendiabiti dove stanno solitamente
le giacche sui manichini allora ci sono
comprato un manichino paio di giorni
dopo realizzate da fatto quando è
arrivato un pacco è enorme con dentro
capitolo chiamato così questo marocchino
di un metro e 94 che da quel momento in
poi è diventato il mio miglior amico
però non lo sai che io questo acquisto
lo rispetto molto
ma niente comprato due anni tu mi stai
dicendo che in questa casa in cantina e
giustamente tu apri la porta e cioè che
sono nate fissa più o meno e mezzo
magnete capitato ho comprato un testo a
parte ale casa apparsi perché poteva
sempre tornare utile ciao
avevo 15 anni era inverno e chiesi a mia
madre ma secondo te è ora che mi compro
non so un cappello
cuffie sarebbero effettivamente di
writer i mercatini è stato amore a prima
vista quella volta quelle devono essere
assolutamente costi quel che costi
neanche un minuto dopo averle indossate
mi sono detta ma perché lo prese riesco
ma che però sono state utilissime in
questi affari sono isolanti quando mio
padre passa l'aspirapolvere accende il
trap non mi posso tranquillamente
leggere paro caso di non sentire nulla
un bacio della musica oggi ascolterò
questo black hand è che tu non hai mai
fatto un acquisto stupido allora ero in
un negozio di bricolage ne ho visto
questo articolo in offerta piede di
porco ho detto come non comprare un
piede di porco tuoi rotondi la sera
scade dica e anche usato che cosa ci fai
o salvato il dito di un vicino perché
gli era rimasto sotto la serranda del
garage e tu sei corso ta capito era
proprio un acquisto inutile al resto è
io credo che sia giusto condividere con
te alcuni miei acquisti o piccolo fetish
per tutto quello che è aggeggio strano
che serve per pulire e trattare la pelle
tool specifico quello reparto con la
cosa più banale è questo bari su questo
è facilissimo spazzolino da denti
questo è un filo interdentale se acqua
compressa o madonna che non è niente ma
ok tipo un'idropulitrice perdenti
bravissime di allora vorrei scarico che
mimmo cosa fare
togli tartaro di pulizia casa fai da te
majesco da morire quando la punta tira
fuori l'incisivo tipo terra quindi del
suo cervello dentro il foro che lascia
il dente resto è facilissimo questo
tutte le ragazze lo conoscono sia
rotelli che una rotellina che passi sul
viso era di ghetti oddio perché ha dei
micro fori che aiutano a stimolare il
collagene a crescere la barba questo e
poi a questo spero funzioni ma cambia
colore
fai sentire il suono bene qui c'è uno
specchietto perché non si può vedere in
questo serve a seconda della luce sia
una truffa si chiama 9 una lampadina ai
contro le impurità cioè 2000 cose è una
lampadina negozi una lampadina in faccia
nel mio preferito o tutte le puntine
varie rose
no questo lo so cos'è la spira odio
questo è lui che aspira tutti quanti
punti che bravo io volevo competere con
un piede di porco ma il mio fidanzato di
notte ha deciso di acquistare 5 litri di
acqua di mare solamente a niente saputa
quando è arrivata la cassa a casa mi
sono chiesta per quale motivo ci fossero
a casa l'acqua di mare lo domandate lui
la risposta è stata la mia pelle sta
molto meglio d'estate quando vado a fare
il bagno quindi d'inverno come faccia a
faccia il bagno con l'acqua di mare
nelle vasche 5 litri o tavola e non ha
mai fatto
e alla fine ci ha cucinato un punto che
figo un polpo a fare questa cosa ma io
guardo ciao ciao matteo
mi sono fatta fare dei grizzlies in oro
bianco pagate la bellezza di 400 euro
usati pensò due volte e poi un giorno ho
deciso di venderli la cosa divertente mi
hanno dato 10 euro vi chiedo di prendere
quella scatola queste sono parte della
collezione strumenti per lavorare il
cuoio
se tu prendi il cuoio non puoi incidere
bagnandolo non l'ho mai fatto quindi
comunque è stato un ottimo acquisto no è
pazzesco queste ancora incellophanata
sono fuorché tease e ciò ospite ad oggi
la cosa più inutile che ho comprato è un
diffusore per capelli o sembra tipo una
proboscide di un elefante che si attacca
l'asciugacapelli l'ho utilizzata solo
una volta e dopo di che ho capito che
era inutile non funzionava quindi l'ho
buttato come succede in fili la testa
dentro questa specie di cuffia c'è
grossa è una cosa a raffica quindi il
formula che sono né lo ha infilato in
quel buco dove tu spari e tutto quanti a
fuoco sicuro oddio dipende il materiale
in questo caso si prende quella più sul
caso matematico ciao ciao matteo e fico
e gianmarco di onesti ascoltando sono
campionessa mondiale di acquisti inutili
da tiger è l'ultimo è stato un canestro
da testa ciao così poi si gioca da
seconda capito bello che brava usa
ospite sono una fan sfegatata del
calzascarpe quindi o in una casa senza
calza scarpe non ci sto mentre
passeggiavo per il negozio vedo questa
meraviglia abbandonata forse tra una
settimana tra due iniziano a
rimpiangerlo però è un cavallo due
cavalli con un occhio da pazzo
[Musica]
che fortuna ad averlo trovato la seconda
meno dai nostri pastori davvero tutti me
lo dicono cappello a forma di tacchino
natalizio
lavate le belle del mondo anche perché
c'è una fissa io per i capelli sono gli
ultimi mesi mi devo prima che cosa che
pensiamo brava bello che a fare quello
il suo collo quello di lui
buongiorno ha ospitato questo più
insensato che ho fatto l'ho fatto circa
un anno fa portatovaglioli a forma di
carpa in lega d'argento 50 euro
sull'unghia per averlo è comunque
interessante un pezzo unico
meno male l'acquisto per eccellenza che
tutti fanno dando del denaro il
abbonamento per la palestra da soli su
sivelli
ma poi non ottieni nulla io c'è un
record abbonamento annuale ci sono
andato una settimana io ho un record
abbonamento annuale un anno ci sono
andato due volte 2 annozero
in tutto sette anni però gli ultimi tre
anni il top di gamma
pensai bene che avresti potuto fare
questo non voglio fare l'eroe
effettivamente no palma gino zhao wei
lui se ciao ospite l'ultimo a questo
stupido che io abbia mai fatto
si tratta di un ciuccio con i passi
bisogna premettere che io non ho figli
non o nipoti non ho nemici che hanno
bambini piccoli sinceramente non so
perché l'ho comprato mi piaceva non lo
userò mai credo meno male ho passato
tutta la prima parte messaggio a dire
vabbè ma si sa c'è di anziché carina
non ho figli e amici
scherzi a parte ragazzi siamo recati
alla fine di questo video è la mia
teoria iniziale posso dire che è
confermato sia la gente ama comprare
delle cose totalmente inutili abbiamo
proprio le lauree nel fare tutto questo
ora posso permettermi di dire che
effettivamente questi soldi potrebbero
essere spesi per un qualcosa di più
concreto come detto all'inizio questo
video in collaborazione con actionaid e
con 9 euro al mese si ha la possibilità
di adottare un bambino a distanza e dare
veramente una mano a chi ne ha bisogno
matteo tu sei stato in africa esatto sai
qual è la cosa [ __ ] quando siamo stati
lì fisicamente per girare delle cose ci
siamo resi conto di quanto questi 9 euro
all'atto pratico possano diventare un
aiuto concreto
noi ci siamo stati a distanza di mesi e
la prima volta che ci sono andato
c'erano dei bambini in una scuola che
facevano lezione sotto un albero dopo
meno di un anno ci sono tornato e la
stessa scuola aveva delle aule in più
costruite fisicamente quindi i bambini
potevano fare lezione in una vera e
propria aula ed era stata costruita con
i soldi delle adozioni a distanza
io ho visto proprio fisicamente nascere
un pezzo di una scuola
la cosa bella poi è che questi 9 euro
non vengono investiti solamente per
quelli che sono beni di prima necessità
che possono essere cibo acqua spese
mediche ma anche per dare la possibilità
a queste persone di crearsi un futuro
autonomo ed è quella una grandissima
svolta adottiamo a distanza un bambino
con actionaid trovate il link qua sotto
soprattutto mostriamo la forza e
possiamo tirar fuori al momento in cui
ci uniamo tutti quanti insieme quindi
che altro dire
dài e dài e dài
[Musica]